Bei Herrn Seiler?
Oh Gott, oh Gott, und denn?
Silke Orphal und Ilona Seeber vor dem Haus,
in dem sie in Berlin gemeinsam gelebt haben.
Als sie hier in jungen Jahren wohnen,
ist ihr Leben alles andere als Privatsache.
Vom Treppenhaus gegenüber
beobachten die Spitzel der Stasi,
des DDR-Geheimdienstes,
sie durchs Küchenfenster.
Früher hatte man von hier
noch ungehinderte Sicht.
Haben Sie denn gesehen,
wie die Stasi-Leute hier gestanden haben?
Nee!
Das hatte ich erst …
also ich zumindest erst gelesen.
Da wären wir im Leben nicht draufgekommen.
Glaub ich auch, ja.
Dass die hier standen und so ...
Da standen sie auch immer direkt …
Sie wissen es aus ihrer Stasi-Akte:
ein paar hundert Blatt Papier,
abgefangene Briefe, private Post,
amtliche Schreiben und vor allem:
Berichte der Spitzel.
Am 30.04.80 um 7 Uhr Observation
am Wohnort aufgenommen.
In der Küche brannte Licht,
und das Fenster war halb geöffnet.
Circa 50 Minuten später
wird das Licht gelöscht, und die Seeber
verlässt allein die Wohnung
und begibt sich zu Fuß
in Richtung U-Bahn Samariterstraße.
Jemand hat in mein Leben geguckt, und
ich hatte keine Ahnung davon.
Und hat auch mich als Person beschrieben
aus seiner Sicht,
die nicht besonders freundlich war.
Es ist da, aber ich leb damit.
So, und ich hab so die Erfahrung gemacht,
dass man immer gut durchs Leben kommt
oder besser fährt,
wenn man mit ’ner Gegebenheit lebt.
Warum wurden die beiden als junge Frauen
überwacht?
Sie kamen aus der Provinz,
finden hier in der Hauptstadt eine gut
bezahlte Arbeit als Schreibkräfte
beim Neuen Deutschland, dem Zentralorgan
der Staatspartei SED – ausgerechnet.
Aber: Sie wollen raus aus der DDR.
Ab 1976 stellen Silke Orphal und Ilona
Seeber immer neue Ausreiseanträge –
mit immer derselben Begründung.
Ich zweifle an der Glaubwürdigkeit
dieses Staates,
da ich es am eigenen Leib
zu verspüren bekommen habe,
wie wenig die Menschenrechte
in der DDR geachtet werden.
Der Nachwende-Generation
müssen die beiden erklären,
warum sie Kopf und Kragen riskiert haben,
um die DDR zu verlassen.
Ich will raus, ich will mir nicht vorschreiben
lassen, wer bestimmt, dass ich hier lebe.
Das hab ich noch nie eingesehen.
Also, das war schon vorher irgendwie,
dass ich
mich damit nicht einverstanden
erklären konnte.
Und da habe ich gedacht,
nee, also, ich will raus. Ich will die Freiheit.
Beinahe wären sie dafür
im Gefängnis gelandet.